d'abord je suis très surpris de
l'utilisation d'un tel terme dans la
bouche d'un président de la république
moi j'avais cru qu'un président de la
république qui étaient là pour
rassembler le peuple
or là il en train de le diviser parce
que stigmatiser aussi la population qui
ne partagent pas ces réformes de traiter
les gens de fainéants c'est évidemment
tout à fait insultant c'est d'autant
plus insultants c'est qu'il faut savoir
quand même que les travailleurs français
sont les plus productifs en europe ou
lors d'une étude qui est paru sur la
productivité du travail donc en europe
et les français sont parmi les plus du
plus productifs d'europe donc je
comprends pas évidemment de tels propos
je crois que ça va contribuer encore
plus je dirais à la mobilisation des
salariés demain pour cette grève
nationale que je soutiens